we were paid twelve hundred and fifty
dollars in one lump sum at the end of
the season we had a raider at handbook
they required me to have bangs and they
also told me to get hair extensions hair
extensions can cost a thousand dollars
very expensive makeup and nails and
tanning
all things that we were required to do
so I've never reimbursed for them we
also received many fines you wore the
wrong thing to practice chewing gum
if you missed a certain amount of
practices you would be fined $40 and we
weren't even paid for practice if they
would weigh us in once a week we didn't
have proper security at times we'll do a
charity appearance at a bowling alley
there's no place for us to change they
do have us change in the restrooms
usually a public restaurant because the
lawsuits were filed they did begin to
pay us minimum wage for every hour that
we work so there has been some change
and hoping that all cheerleaders all
across the entire NFL will be able to be
compensated fairly and treated according
to the law